the biggest thing that I had a question
on was um John 173 and I was actually
reading through um your article on on
answering Islam after after the debate
um so that was that was really the only
point I feel like I didn't answer answer
thoroughly so if you could yeah sum up
his sum up his position again what was
his position by John 173 uh well
basically he just the same Muslim
argument that that you'll get and you
know the father is the only only true
God yeah it was actually worse than that
he kept repeating the following and I
try to count how many times he did it
and then I just got tired if you go back
guys and watch the debate on Chris
Claus's Channel he didn't simply quote
John 173 to say the father is only your
God he kept saying the father alone is
the only true God the Father alone now
right there that's adding to scripture
that's perverting scripture and God
saido not add to his word lest he expose
you as a liar because that does change
the whole meaning to say the father
alone is the only true God is different
from saying the father is the only true
God it's not the same now people think
we're splinting hairs no because when
you say the father is the only true God
that would be true but is he the only
true God in isolation or in Union with
the Son and the spirit so right of
course yeah to say the father is the
only true God okay in
isolation or in Union with the Son and
the spirit but when you say the father
alone is the only true God then that's a
different story so so he kept butchering
that passage he kept twisting and
distorting that passage because if it
did say that it would make his case but
it doesn't so with that said I don't
really
see I mean because we've answered this a
million times I don't see how this
proves their case because it shows an
inconsistency on their part what do I
mean the Bible will often use
restrictive language one only none but
in a sense that doesn't imply that there
is a way in which others others also
partake of or United to that particular
quality or characteristic what do I mean
by that the Bible will talk about
only none and yet the same Bible will
then mention other individuals that
share in or possess that characteristic
that was just stated to belong to only
one entity and I'll give you a passage
in reference to the Lord Jesus Christ go
to Jude if you don't mind open up the
Bible go to Jude because I don't know
what version he prefers as well do you
guys know what Bible he
prefers the one that uh fits fits his
narrative and then that's yeah then
that's going to be difficult yes I it's
hard to nail this guy because he plays
Bible ping pong he'll go with any
translation that suits his purpose so
this is this is one bad fruit of a
plethora Bible versions and I just want
share this with people it is a blessing
that we have so many versions of the
Bible in various languages especially in
English but it's also a curse in that
when you're dealing with
anti-trinitarian Heretics or
cultists they will do Bible ping pong
they will jump from one translation to
another and they will not stick to any
one translation because to them it
doesn't matter what the Bible says it's
what they can make the Bible say to
support their satanic man-made doctrines
so if they're reading the King James
they'll stick with the King James until
the King James doesn't prove helpful for
their cause and this is what I call
Bible ping pong and we as Christians we
need to stop doing that as much as we
can let me further qualify that I'm not
saying it'll be wrong to look at another
translation if that translation provides
greater Clarity so that someone can see
the point much clearly but that's not
what these cultists are doing these
cultists will abandon a particular
translation that they use in order to
read a different version that has a
different reading altogether that's what
I mean by Bible pingpong but with that
said if you go to Jude it's only one
chapter 25 verses uh for some men who
were designated for this judgment long
ago have come in by stealth they are
ungodly turning the grace of our God
into promiscuity and denying Jesus
Christ Our Only master and Lord okay now
that's the word Manas the very word he
was arguing about now Jesus Christ is
said to be the only master and Lord now
if he's going to be consistent which
he's not he's going to have to rule out
the father from being our despot because
the word Master is the word despotas
it's in accusative I'm not trying to get
technical but it's actually Jesus Christ
is our only despot and Lord the word
Lord is C
so it's two different words therefore if
we apply that
heric that says that because the
father is the only true God and
therefore Jesus and the spirit are ruled
out then Jesus is the only Sovereign and
Lord kuras that means the father can't
be kuras Kus Lord nor can he be despot
despot obviously that's nonsense because
we know that Jesus is the only master
and Lord in Union with the
father not to the exclusion of the
father now I was hoping someone bring
this objection Jeremy did now Jeremy I
want to answer it but I prefer you call
and I answer for you because the King
James doesn't help him either it
actually proves Jesus is called the only
Lord God and our only Lord Jesus Christ
because it's a grandal sharp
construction so Jeremy call me after
this so we can deal with it but so he
would say no that doesn't rule out the
father well why should the statement the
father being the only true God rule
Jesus out when the entirety of the
Gospel of John and John's letters
identify Jesus as being essentially one
with the father in that he and the
father possess the same Divine ability
nature and Glory that would be my
response now I don't want to keep
ranting because I want to help you if
you have any you have a followup because
I want to show you other things related
to John 173 yeah as long as nobody else
is calling you uh if if they do I have
no problem bowing out I'll call you back
yeah yeah no so that was that was really
good with uh Jude 4 it makes total sense
because if um it would rule out uh
Yahweh in his in his um understanding as
being master and Lord then right so
that's an absurd position 100% And he
can't do that but he's going to explain
it away like he always does but I'm
gonna give you another one now remember
when you said who is the word he said
the word is not a who it's a what right
so we're going to kill two birds with
one stone right now because we're going
to show that according to Jesus
according to Jesus's Revelation to John
according to Jesus Revelation John he
just excluded the father and the Holy
Spirit from knowing as much as Jesus
does because the Revelation to John was
given to him by the Lord Jesus Christ so
go to Revelation 19 and read 12-13 if
you read for us now notice how we're
going to turn this against
him right so his eyes were like a fiery
flame and many crowns were on his head
he had a name written that no one knows
except himself so the father doesn't
know and the Holy Spirit doesn't know so
Jesus is more knowledgeable than the
father and the son I mean the father and
the Holy Spirit yeah you're just
unlocking all kinds of stuff in my brain
thank you uh he wore a robe stained with
blood and his name is the word of God
but I thought the word is not a who it's
a what yeah but it says his yeah but
that's got to be a mistake man
so you saw you just killed two birds one
stone you first demonstrated yeah that
Jesus is the only one who knows his name
who has a name that no one knows except
himself so that means the father is not
as knowledgeable and doesn't know as
much as the son does neither does the
Holy Spirit and then here Jesus is the
word of God so it's not a what it's a
who now obviously as trinitarians we
would argue that when something is said
about let's say a member of the godhead
whether the father's Holy Spirit where
the father alone is good or Jesus is the
only master and Lord or no one knows the
name of Jesus except himself that is not
intended to exclude father and spirit
but exclude all creatures in other words
no creature no one or nothing that's not
God can know the name similarly when it
says the father is the only true God to
the exclusion of all these others who
are falsely worshiped named and called
God but not to the exclusion of the Son
and the spirit because the Bible has
given us enough evidence to show he's
the only true God in Union with his son
and spirit not to the exclusion of
either the son or the spirit so Jesus
knows the name in Union with the father
and the spirit not to the exclusion of
the father and spirit no one here means
no creature who's not
God and we know this
from passages such as Matthew 11:27 and
Luke 10:22 where there Jesus says it's
the same saying all things have been
handed to me by my father no one knows
who the son is except the father and no
one knows who the father is except the
son and to whom the son chooses to
reveal him well if the father knows the
son the way the son knows the father and
the son knows the Father the way the
father knows the son if I were to ask
him which he wouldn't answer he try to
get around it does the father know the
son exhaustively comprehensively inside
and out and every thought of the sun of
course that means if the son knows that
name and the father knows the son
comprehensively exhaustively then he too
must know the name that the son knows
because he knows everything about the
son
right but it's reciprocal it says then
the son knows the Father the way the
father knows him well the father has an
omniscient mind and he knows the son
exhaustively inside and out
comprehensively and knows all his
thoughts but then Jesus says the son
knows the father in the same way which
would be blasphemy if he's a creature
because no creature can know an
omniscient mind who's incomprehensible
to the same extent that omnicient mind
knows
him right right but then Jesus affirms
that he's incomprehensible because he
says no one knows the son except the
father meaning the son is so
incomprehensible that it requires a mind
like the father's mind to know him
truly so this is how we interpret
scripture we don't do Bible ping pong
and take one verse out of the context
and just to show you that Jesus is
claiming the father is only true God in
Union with him in Union with him not to
his to the exclusion of the son go to
John 10
27-30 this is why you need the son along
with the spirit to make God known
because only the Son and the spirit are
qualified to reveal the true nature and
essence of God but in John 10 27- 30
yeah it says my sheep hear my voice I
know them and they follow me I give them
eternal life and they will never perish
ever no one will snatch them out of my
hand my father who has given them to me
is greater than all no one is able to
snatch them out of the father's hand the
father and I are one now this refutes
his other Canard where he says that's
God doing that because if it was God the
father doing it there would be no need
for Jesus to
differentiate his hand from the father's
hand no one plucks them out of my hand
no one plucks them out of my father's
hand because we are one hold on Jesus
but it's not you doing anything it's the
father so why are you saying your hand
and contrasting it with the father's
hand does that make sense according to
his view no it does yet any I mean not
on his view but the the the father and I
are one I mean that pretty much just
summarizes the whole thing right there
but now he he would point to passages
where it says others are one with God
but I'll tell you how to refute that
very easily that's why he's listening so
if he's man enough to call let him call
let me explain to you number one even
the verb R esmen if you look at the
Greek it's plural we are R it's esmen
it's plural we are one now how do we
know that Jesus saying he's one with the
father not in purpose like some of these
Heretics will say yes he's unified
United to the father in purpose and will
but in power and therefore Essence
because 2728 brother pay attention
carefully Jesus says they're my sheep
they hear my voice they're in my hand my
sheep in my hand hand meaning a metaphor
hand for protection care provision power
because when you think of hand you use
your hand to strike to resist to protect
so on and so forth so hand here means
that the Sheep are under
Jesus's care and protection and because
Jesus is Almighty there's no one that
can destroy any sheep that's under his
care and protection my sheep and my hand
never perish right so here's what I want
you to focus on my sheep my voice in my
hand and no one and and they have
everlasting life so my sheep my voice my
hand and everlasting life now go to
Psalm 95 and read for
68 Psalm 95: 68
come let us worship and bow down let us
kneel before the Lord our maker for he
is our God and we are the people of his
pasture the Sheep under his care now
your your translation did you the
service here because literally the
Hebrew says the Sheep of his hand yeah
it says literally in the foot nose
literally sheep of his hand yeah and you
need that leral translation to make the
connection so it says we are the flock
of his pasture and the Sheep of his hand
right right okay and then what else does
it say uh today if you hear his voice do
not Harden your hearts as uh at maraba
as on the day at Messa in the wilderness
okay I'm confused here it says the
people of God are the Sheep of his hand
under his care and protection and
they're supposed to hear Jehovah's voice
Jesus says they are my sheep in my hand
who hear my
voice right but then the Lord says I
give everlasting life and none can
deliver out of my hand
right Deuteronomy
3239 Deuteronomy 32:39 watch
there
32 uh see now that I alone am he there
is no God but me I bring death and I
give life I wound and I heal no one can
rescue anyone from my hand now again the
Christian Standard Bible does a
paraphrases more than it translates
literally it's okay I give life and none
can deliver out of my
hand none can deliver out of my hand
right so here Jehovah says he's the one
who gives life and none can deliver out
of his hand but Jesus just said I give
everlasting life and none can deliver
out of my
hand the final one will be Isaiah 43
13 43 you said 13 yep Isaiah
43:13 uh also from today on I am he
alone and no one can deliver from my
hand I act and who can reverse it why
does Jesus speak as if he's Jehovah god
of the Old Testament though he's not the
father because he just said what Jehovah
says my sheep in my hand under my care
they are to hear my voice I I give life
none can deliver out of my hand and
Jesus says not only does he give life he
gives everlasting life Immortal Life
Incorruptible life to all the
sheep and so it's in this context that
Jesus says I and the father are one one
in what in our ability and power to
Grant Immortal Life NeverEnding morally
Incorruptible life to all the Sheep
guaranteeing their Everlasting
preservation that's why in John 10 31:33
the Jews picked up stones to Stone him
then he asked him many good works I've
shown you from the father for which of
these do you Stone me for good work we
do not Stone you the Jews answered but
for blasphemy and because you are man
make yourself out to be God so they
understood it and Jesus doesn't correct
them by saying no it's the god in me he
shows well even corrupt evil Wicked
immoral rulers can be called Gods how
dare you falsely slander me by saying
I'm blasphemy because I said I'm the Son
of God when the Miracles I do prove the
father is in Union with me and I and the
father together are working because I
have the same ability the father does to
do what the father does and the Miracles
I do is the Father's amen of my claims
he is confirming my claims I'm no
blasphemer so that's right there from
John you're told that when it says the
father is the only true God in Union
with his son who apart from the son does
nothing the son does nothing apart from
the Father the father does nothing apart
from the Sun so that's how I interpret
John 17 and then verse one says Jesus
looked up to heaven and said father The
Hours come glorify your son so that your
son may glorify you now I don't know if
it's going to sink in with Taylor but
this is blasphemy for a creature why
because notice what he's saying he's
it's demanding he's commanding and
demanding which he can do lovingly
because he knows who he is the Father's
Heart whom the father always hears
glorify your son so that it's
conditional you want me to glorify you
you got to glorify me and glorify me the
way I glorify you can a creature speak
that
way not rightfully and yet Jesus does
and this is right before
three and then in two which he's going
to try to explain away it says well and
it says and you've given him all author
authority over All Flesh oh see he was
given Authority he do have it therefore
he's not God right but here's the point
where he's going to have to do the tap
dance
you've given him authority over All
Flesh so that he the son may give
everlasting life to all you've given him
now this is not the god in him doing it
because he's saying you father are
giving them to me so I personally will
give them everlasting life well if it's
the god in him doing it then it makes no
sense for him to say you are giving
sheep for you then to give life through
me right and that's where verse three
comes comes in now he explains what it
means so you want me the son to give
everlasting life to you if the father's
given you to me well here's how you're
going to get it you better know my
father is the only true God and me his
son Jesus Christ whom you've sent now
here knowing means to know intimately
and to know personally and be in
fellowship with well how can
Jesus have intimate fellowship and
communion with anyone the way the father
does if he's limited and he's not
omniscient
omnipresent yeah
can understand the implication of
knowing here it's not head knowledge oh
yeah yeah I know God it's saying You
must come into an
intimate
personal Fellowship communion loving
relationship with the father and the son
you have to be in communion and
fellowship with both equally well I
understand how that's possible with the
father because the father is omnipresent
so wherever you're at you have access to
him and he has access to you and you can
be in communion with him but how can
this apply to Jesus because it's not now
the God in Jesus because he's saying
Jesus
Christ right so how can you have
intimate loving communion which you must
have to experience everlasting life with
Jesus if Jesus is not truly God but
simply a man that God
indwells yeah see I mean that buries him
but it just again it's talking to you
know it's like talking to a brick wall
with
him yeah well and that that I mean I I
appreciate you being able to to walk us
through everything as well and and and
read through it